live there's been too much distraction
lately with all the stuff I'm doing
around
puffer this Dev just needs to get done
like this the core patch here is what's
important at the moment it just needs to
be
done um we are basic at a spot where all
of the hard decisions have been
made there are a few things that I'm not
you know 100% satisfied
with uh but it's still a generational
leap from what we had
before
and Analysis paralysis feature creep all
these dumb things these are not
important what is important is getting
this patch
shipped in a reasonable State as fast as
is humanly possible
including the
environments I think I was stuck on
logging for the mobo right that was like
the last major environment thing
here I think that's the
case let me see what was going on with
this I think it was the way I was
handling the logs was a little bit
confusing yeah okay so
we have logs
here let's just compile this see and see
uh where we left
off this is going to get merged into Dev
today it just has to be and then uh I'm
fine doing that on a Friday because I'll
be working on it all day tomorrow
anyways so if anything breaks I'll just
be able to fix that in Dev
um yeah so this was not finished for
sure let's piix some of these
strong
uh logs logs of
ual oh yeah I just have the initializer
syntax wrong
here yeah
so I don't know if I like this the way
that these logs
are completely yet I think it gets a
little simpler though
right yeah hold on what is happening
here
so wait no this initializer syntax is
fine isn't it
oh no wait hold on so aggregated logs
then okay so these are the global
stats and
then the individual stats I suppose
okay so it's not terrible
wait player log
star individual
I'm trying to think how I was doing this
before
I don't think you need
this I think that this is
right and then episode length there's no
episode length I guess
yeah there is no episode thing so I just
I got some wires
crossed hi welcome doing all right just
need to get all this stuff done
today really need this patch to
up so you have log
log and then you have log
buffer hey
Will yeah I'm trying to ship it's just
there's a lot of code in this update
there's a lot of stuff
it's mostly the new
environments they all have to be like in
reasonable working
welcome yeah it's literally like the
core of puffer is only a few thousand
lines and this update is adding like
10,000 plus lines of C just in
simulators
and I'm very much enjoying the sea but
it has been 10 years since I've written
C and uh there were a few growing panes
that I had to like work around and then
I had to like refactor a bunch of
times what I'm looking at now
potentially being one of those which is
finding a decent way to do logging from
these
environments um multiple en environments
and see into python
cleanly
players yeah this isn't going to
work the way I have
to pretty sure I can just do player logs
here got to get back to slop good luck
we'll actually we'll leave the name as
log but then this thing needs to
have player log I think
yeah this doesn't need to have log this
needs to
have uh a player
then I should be able to do it like this
I believe
right player PID Target
PID and then we do a
player is it
player log healing dealt Target log
healing
received and then here this is Target
Health
player yeah so we replace this with the
log
uses oh
yeah we're not going to need this
anymore because it's no longer being
cracked so
ridiculously okay so this is a
slightly less ridiculous
mess this portion here we get to get rid
of this like crazy redundant conditional
Q I'm tempted to Nest
it let's do this at least
yeah we got rid of most of the Redundant
things in here
already basic attack
uses no not
Union this is where
it's making a new log right
buffer this is fine all I have to do is
make the log here so we just do log
log
zero log. episode
length all
ah and
this gets to be removed as
well I believe
it I think this is it
because yeah we don't need to do this
copy anymore
so this type of thing maybe we can
adjust
thing like we're overwriting some
address somewhere it's weird you'd think
that the sanitizer would be able to
catch that
let me see if I like the way that this
is working at the moment though we've
got this log
I think it's good this way so let me see
is there anything I can cut out of this
I don't think I can I think I have to
keep it this way but that's really not
bad to do all the aggregation
logic I might be able to clean it up a
little bit but that's not like painfully
bad uh provided that
the the version at the bottom is fine
logs I'm actually kind of curious as to
how this uh this type of bug happens
because I haven't seen this before
H are there other address sanitizer
Flags I can use
perhaps
because this one doesn't make much sense
weird I mean I
guess the log address
initialized I mean we initialized log
buffer
right I did mess with a bunch of these
variables
player log doesn't have any pointers in
it
right allocate allocates
Vlogs
oh I wonder
if I could be out of bounds
on uh the ne there could be like a
negative one going to one of the logs
let me look up at sanitized real quick F
sanitize args
oh I'm not uh I'm missing Flags
here yeah so here let's just immediately
TCG let's
grab let's grab this
there we go you see like C is a totally
different language with and without good
address sanitizer like with a good
address sanitizer see is
amazing this is literally all you need
right
here if you don't know that exists
you're kind of just screwed
though yeah so here we
have uh this looks like a of divide by
zero
right Max Mana does this not get set
somehow
now I like messed
up oh and then uh
index 30 here
player pit is negative one
here or no wait player pit is
oh I see yeah cuz I forgot I forgot some
stuff
yeah I mainly I just have to clean up
these environments and add a few more
Bells not even Bells a few more
compatibility things to the
main library uh I guess the main thing
with contributors at the moment is just
like once I merge this in today I'm
going to want some good baselines on all
the different
environments and
uh yeah some of the people that
contributed the original code for these
don't have have time to run those
experiments at the
moment like here I'll show you basically
the new
update is all of these couple more as
well that are in the development plus a
lot of surrounding infr and stuff um
we'd like to have good policies trained
not this one yet but like these four
need good trained policies this one
probably needs like a better built-in
these both probably need better built-in
like scripted opponent AIS um stuff like
that and like training all that
stuff want to do this
thing for
scripted Baseline sounds fun yeah
like I I think Spencer who is in the uh
the Discord has been chatting about like
doing MCTS or like just breath for
search or something for some of these
games um but yeah like having that stuff
nicely integrated would be good I mean
the code for these is not that bad
either and uh Spencer is usually around
he wrote These two M's
I just like touch them up a little
bit but essentially like here I'll check
the bind Branch this is getting merged
into Dev today but I'll look at this for
now cuz it's
cleaner um essentially like with the new
update there's a bunch of infra and API
stuff that I have to deal with but as
you can see I'm also having to spend a
lot of time on individual environments
here in order to get everything nice and
clean with the new version and like
there's this whole other side of stuff
that needs to get done before we can
release this which is having the
baselines and if you look in here like
here are all the M's here's Connect 4
connect 4. it's only a couple hundred
lines of code Spencer wrote this I just
added all this log stuff in right but
like there's no opponent AI for this
thing
so there's no real way to set it to a
difficulty or whatever so you purely
have to train through selfplay
which is kind of cool like cuz we want
to do a bunch of selfplay stuff as well
but like if we want to treat it as a
single agent environment with like a
fixed just fast opponent doesn't have to
be crazy good um yeah we're going to
need something like that and it's a
little tricky cuz it has to be fast
right like all these environments we're
usually aiming to run them in a million
steps per second um but it you should at
least be able to get like some very
basic like search thing that evaluates a
couple moves like a few different moves
and chooses the best one something like
that you know maybe even something as
simple as doing like two-step look ahead
would be good
search I guess it's a little obnox just
because you kind of want to have like
Fast State set stuff for that which is
something that we're going to do in the
future
um but yeah literally even a greedy AI
like even just like a greedy Baseline
would literally be good enough just like
doesn't immediately make a losing move
would already be good
enough just cuz like right now the AI is
literally like it wins just by stacking
all of the the coins or all the tokens
in one
side yeah if you're interested in that
drop in a Discord ggp puffer right
that's where all the dev is happy to
help with stuff over there
coordinating but I got to finish these
freaking logs
super new to all this glad to see
someone streaming their work and thre
process yeah I I
mean a lot of my stuff is not intended
to be primarily educational it's more
like pushing the research forward but
the thing is the way that I've built all
this stuff like it just so happened to
work out this way where we have people
with zero RL experience building ultra
high perf Sims like in a day now because
we've kind of taken away the obnoxious
RL portions of it and it's really just
like building like low-level games um
and lowl Sims so if you're interested in
getting involved with stuff we can
definitely use the uh use the
help like uh as I always say these these
four here were all built by contributors
who are brand new to RL
and this one here this TCG I built this
prototype but like this is going to be
an upcoming project where I'm hoping
that contributors will like largely want
to uh help expand this into like a
bigger card game type environment for RL
yeah I can't do it this way this is so
obnoxious the way that this code is is
here
I guess I have to do this just once at
the
top we'll figure out a better way to do
this later but I think for now I can
just do like player log star player
log I can just do like
if if player to
type
else now we're not going to do end log
zero like this it's going to
be player
something like
this
it oh cuz it's running a perf test I'm
dumb yeah okay it'll take a
second and the perf test will be slow
because I'm compiling I've compiled with
all this address sanitizing stuff
got all right we've got like we've got
some uh some stuff
here to mess
with uh I think that we just
didn't bother
fixing yeah so we'll fix this
stuff but here we've
got this is
done uh can I
train can I train this already will this
work
oh jeez what is
this
ah I uh I didn't update the
headers I just
need I probably need all the headers
don't
okay I hope that this works the way I
think it does I think that what'll
happen is if you Nest strs like this uh
I think when you convert them to python
they'll get converted into a nested
dictionary which is very slow but this
only
happens um once every like tens of
thousands of agent steps so this should
be
fine yeah we have to update all the
headers though because now I'm thinking
about it I like I mean it's a big
Improvement but uh I did kind of mess
with a lot of the struck deaths didn't I
all right so here's all the entity stuff
there's still a whole bunch of stuff in
here but it's at
smaller it's it's kind of funny like
having done this project like I'm glad I
did this MOBA type thing and this is
going to be a great M to build off of
but like I want to do more you know
slightly smaller scope things than this
cuz this just D like something of this
size just drags on too long you know
it's very difficult to get something
like this fully done uh
quickly ask her we'll just leave the
semicolons it doesn't
matter do we have two entity structs in
here thought I already did that
one
no wait this
is I'm dumb this is
entity this is
entity then I need to go get the
mistru the mistru header
see and this is actually this needs to
be defined below I believe as well
okay so this
runs where my logs
though Aggregate and
clear oh wait yeah I remember games
don't actually
finish so I need to I need to
artificially inject this
here let's just do
Rand
Z so we're just going to artificially um
artificially you know uh return logs
more often than I normally would just
for now
right this is actually returning logs
correctly
unroll nested
dick I think this is what we want right
and
fog let's see if this does it
why are we not getting this into the
logs
be oh there we
go
okay so now this is a ton of stats
right and then we'll figure out why
uh it's flashing like this
interval no it's literally just the
interval that's fine then
so there you go we actually do
have uh basic
monitoring and now we have to debug the
environment itself a little bit I
think but that
is that's way better than we had a
second ago
let's go figure out some of these memory
bugs let's go figure out some memory
bugs soon as I just check the Discord
real quick see if I missed
anything
discord.gg
puffer for
this go ahead and start the repo as well
[Music]
yeah so something here
tower OBS map gets zeroed
right and observations yes OBS map does
get
zeroed we'll just do if
it's greater than
zero
right do
fixes very easy for a couple small bugs
like this to screw up learning
if you get NS and
stuff usually you would notice that with
like hardend crashes but
uhoh
oops build
this see what is doing damage outside of
range
25 oh yeah that could be out of bounds
I guess I should kind of just
arbitrarily Norm this
hit oh yeah this scaling on everything
here is just super
so this one is
weird oh no wait no it
isn't 25 times
apparently uh servers should be back
online I'm going go check on
those that's really nice cuz uh that
means we can maybe queue up some
experiments
later tail scale
back all but one are back let me go
figure that out real quick hold on I'll
be back in 30 seconds
all but one of them came back
online so we actually have servers which
is good because we have lots of stuff to
throw at those let me tell the team
they'll be very happy
interesting
this let me just tell the team real
quick
components
XP times n reward XP
[Music]
now okay I know I remember what I was
trying to do with this janky
model okay so you can see
there
is a divide by 255 here
right there's a divide by
255 so what I was trying to essentially
do is um make a one bite
float I
guess
um yeah because I'd have to make a one
bite float because otherwise
I mean like technically you could
do I don't know is there a one bite
float probably would be better to just
do what I'm
OBS en coding is going to need work I
don't think that that's going to be our
major job though for right
see and then player damage
here
damage what's like the max damage we're
assuming that things could
50 30 *
25 700 like 750 is I think
good move speed move
mod rest of this is good
Type
[Music]
yeah so the thing is we're not going to
know
the scaling of these so I should
probably just do
like
reward
death
uh
zero Els
255 all right Ops extra
20 it's going to
so it's just Zer to
oneing cuz we don't have the Precision
basically to deal with it so let's do
here these are the Ops on the map which
is the
level this is
normed 0 to one 0 to 1 0 to
one yeah these are already Norm 0 to
one see if we o i mean out of bounds not
om
and we can mess with the network a
little bit oh and then I can actually
already start running this on the
box which will be very
nice I think we'll probably just hard
merge as soon as I fix up a couple last
things
here hard merge into Dev
so hey man love your work been super
into RL for the last two years love to
do my masters in the US have you any
tips on what to focus on to get a
scholarship uh as a European student o I
don't know much about master
scholarships to be honest usually in the
US yeah there are
scholarships um I think it's usually the
case that you pay for Masters but they
pay you for
phds there are
like uh there are Grant programs and
stuff hold
on I think they're mostly for PhD
students am I wrong
here uh CS
Vector yeah but these are
not
yeah I honestly don't know a ton about
uh for masters programs um I can tell
you though in the US uh if you're
interested in it you don't do a uh a PhD
in the US after a masters you go
straight from undergrad to PhD and you
don't pay to do a PhD you get paid not
much but you get paid a stipend uh as a
PhD student and you don't pay
tuition um so that's generally what
people
do a lot of the Master's prog like a lot
of the master students I know at good
programs in the US like they do it joint
with their undergrad often times so
they'll get like they'll get their
masters during their undergrad
taken so yeah game just got
one all right so something is happening
here at
least well to adjust this a little bit
and such but it's
interesting it's so
unbalanced well it's okay for now though
um cool so this
now this now works mostly
this is pretty
clean get rid of
this trying to think what other major
things I
need before I can start merging
stuff
um I don't want to get hung up on the
experiments initially right
there was one other feature that we
wanted but I don't think I want to do
that right now I don't think it's crazy
high
priority I think that we're kind of in a
good spot with this to be
honest
um what happens if I run this without V
native
yeah let's just figure that out and then
let's merge and then uh I'll just like
warn people in the Discord that we're
going to do a hard merge into Dev and if
anybody has any problems and is on the
dev Branch uh to let me know so that we
Unbreak
things I think that's going to be the
main the main thing at the moment
okay warnings have been issued welcome
YouTube
folks this is good though I mean like
all these M's
now all of these M's have except this
one but all these M's have uh really
clean simple API on everything now hold
on oh hold on guys I need to just check
the
servers we have uh all the machines that
we run stuff
the this box is still
down U let me see
[ __ ] I think that they broke one of our
boxes in shipping
guys that's not
good essentially there was a there was a
hurricane in Florida and we run all of
our stuff on this so these had to be
like like you know locked up for
Hurricane so they didn't get taken out
uh one of them though we had to ship for
maintenance and I think they might have
broken it well nothing we can do about
that at the
moment we'll see
think what El before the merge right
there was the one VEC thing okay I know
where we were so the one thing I wanted
to make sure is I wanted to make sure
that with the new environment format
this is the new well not this one um but
with the new environment format we want
to make sure that we can run it with
everything else
oh
uh
is we can probably come up with a
way to make this work with the new VC
format
so essentially we're going to have
something that's compatible with
gynasium um petting zoo but also this
super fast puffer native
format the bad news is it does look like
it's going to take a little bit of
thought on just just how to do
that let me
see step actions
it's actually not that bad
though
surprisingly well wait a second maybe it
is bad
yeah it has to be special case so what
happens
here um is that in the gymnasium and
petting zoo formats you see how we have
this weird buffer injection thing this
is not going to work for our custom M's
because the buffers have to be created
earlier um so I have to special case it
up here I think
let me figure out how to do this I think
though that like if I just do this now
this
solves this solves the last major
problem we were
having you know this solves the last
major problem we were
having and it's not that hard if I just
think about it a little bit
is
it it actually might be a little bit
this might be a bit much to think about
right
now I can just set vectorization in
Native though for these
environments
I think that's a good quick fix for now
so I can
actually yeah
let's we're going to commit this for
Moa
modified that's just an executable we
don't care about
that for
uh and then the native VC thing is going
to have to be we're going to have to fix
GPU drive with this I'm
though and
then all these things that aren't
tracked let me see if there's anything
we missed
here untracked files
I don't think we need any of
this
mode that's a big push that's a big uh
commit
we're going to hard merge this into Dev
and
then uh it's going to just be as much
coffee as it takes in order to get this
thing stable
today but this needs to be in Dev so I
can test it
okay get pull now we are actually going
to be able to test
okay so now what we
do we go on to the bigger box
so there are a number of things we can
do at the moment with these M's
um I think we kind of just start with
the simple ones we run basic
sweeps and we see how that goes
so first of all
okay so we get to
here
uh
P
Dev
we're going to rebuild all the M's and I
think we're going to just go through one
at a time and try to uh to learn on them
though okay so it's missing a close
function we'll add
that that'll be uh somewhat
important but what we're going to do is
just locally here
oh for folks uh who do use
x uh this is where I post all the RL
stuff you also get stream notifications
here anyways let me see want to go W to
B and I post like exclusively RL stuff I
don't post like random politics and
memes well some memes very
rarely I try not to get too bored on X
and keep it just
research okay so here is our pong
experiment see it goes right up like
this episode length still going up is
odd
uh we're going to have to mess with it a
little bit most
likely where's my
model no model
here it because it didn't save
cleanly probably
so so let's just let's just fix that
CL
close free self
M you have to do free self. logs as well
I believe
over one mil train is nice
though should be able to go way faster
than that even
but what happened
here data. vm. close
oh was the maybe the file just didn't
save yeah we're
good I want to see this policy if it
actually does anything
here's our
file we can just copy
this and go to our local machine so we
can
this got to be my pong I think we'll
rename these but this is the ocean
version of
okay so this is not
good it's getting one hit back because
it's just like by default I
guess h
go back to 100 Mil we're not going to
actually need 100 Mil but for testing
purposes I want to make sure this is
actually going up
this
um thing is the crazy batch size should
not actually be helpful for
pong
theoretically we'll see whether that
ends up being true
episode length going up means it's doing
something
here it's totally learning it's just not
learning efficiently as
all so we can totally just run a hyper
pram sweep on
this yeah and you can see score as
well this particular set doesn't seem to
be very
stable but we should be able to I mean
these are like one minute experiments
two minute experiments right
this
four and
then don't need
these total time steps
though oh there isn't so it won't
actually sweep this which is
good and then I guess all we do is we
mess with the batch size which is going
to be from
16k 32 okay do
16 3
4 2
one we'll do like
oh I think that's
it the mini batch size will go
from 36 up to
K
see how many carbs experiments we're
running at the
moment carbs
here and I'll explain this in a
second 500 is
fine okay so
here what we are going for here is is a
autotuned version of this to see if we
just can automatically solve this
environment which given how easy this is
we really should be able
here we can see we get the first point
coming
in right here's your train
curve and we're going to get all these
graphs uh in
here and this is not going to take very
long CU these experiments run in about a
minute a
piece
um let going to go use the restroom real
quick I'm going to grab a tile andol
actually as well getting a headache from
this
um and then we're going to see if this
works if this works we're going to
repeat this process for all the other
M's and then we're going to hopefully be
able to even ship baselines today which
would be very very nice I'll be right
back
forgot to unmute the mic anyways so
literally second run here the problem is
solved
right literally second ever
size little bit of
entropy very low Lambda Gamma makes
sense for
pong tweaks the learning rate manyi bad
size yeah
cool um
we'll let this run for a little bit
maybe or should we move
on let's do something in between
let's let's just grab these hyper
parameters right
I like how it tries to autofill some
random
value what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to paste these
in and um
then I'm going
to oops I'm going to paste these in I'm
going to train this locally while the
sweep is still going and then uh
hopefully we'll actually have a
reasonable policy
so that's
it everything there is set
mil I can set Baseline on it as well so
that we'll save this policy for
training now mind you like it's using a
ton of samples um but that's not what we
have this optimized for right we're
optimizing this to train quickly and
also we haven't we haven't run a sweep
yet uh very very likely you know we're
going to find some settings that train
this very quickly as well and that'll be
interesting to see and then this will
basically serve as uh your new test M
for stuff so instead of doing cartpole
as a test end you have something a
little bit more complex I'd say than
cartpole
uh but that also trains very fast
because Atari Pong would take freaking
two hours with sp3 or
whatever and now here you have it
with why here you have it like
instantly so saying that uh these
parameters don't seem to be performing
as well as in the original experiment
let's figure out
why oh so it
took it took like 40 mil in the original
let's give it 40
mil again not optimized
whoops this one here
oh yeah we also have to fix
these
this then in the meantime let me make
sure I actually got all the parameters
correctly from this so I think I
probably did it's probably just like I
stopped it right
oops Yeah you can actually see already
look at that so just in the time it took
me to do that look there's already one
that solves it faster
here also this axis should probably be
agent steps or time train time is also
good I think we like
time relative time so 20 seconds to
solve 30 seconds actually it'll be 20 by
the time we're done I'm
sure so here we
are 17
yeah this one this time it's actually
already good by 25 so you can see
there's some variability
we also can probably try this like
without the RNN and with like a simpler
Network or whatever so there's a little
Baseline for it
okay this is now running
evals and then we should be able to load
this up and watch
it it should full solve the
game
2,000 length
episodes about 100 uh per step
policy amusingly uh this game this game
of pong is like I cannot play this very
well well I can only get a few points
per round so this is much better than me
at the
policy it's actually surprisingly nice
and reasonable how that uh how that
works
this is how RL should be right like you
just run a little sweep you solve your
environment this is an easy environment
you run the same thing on harder ends
you get the exact same sort of behavior
just take some more experiments and
whatever but yeah this policy seems to
match exactly as we
expect um
oops policy is it is using an RNN it
looks like probably doesn't need it but
it'll use it anyways it's
fine yeah
and we will see you how much quicker it
can solve
this but right
now 24 seconds 25
seconds I think this is Nathan's pong
end right
we could make it harder by uh changing
the reward function around a little bit
but I'm happy with this for now
you know what why don't we just leave
this going on this box here let's just
leave that going on this
box let's commit our pams
I'll have to give uh Spencer a time
share on this one as well
confused I guess there's no no there is
a breakout
why is there I'm confused as
to why there's no uh config in here are
any files
not committable or something weird
oh yeah that's weird I don't
know now we've got it
yep okay here's our
n let's see if we have a close error on
them
as well let's just see how fast it
rebuild trains over a
million as it
should start scoring
points not a lot of points and the exits
clean
it's the main thing
100 million
steps for
sweep we do batch size is going to go
from what did we do for this um long
end 16
K let's go a little higher than
this 16k
six oh yeah this is fine
actually
16 this should be
good yeah this should be good
and then the expectation is we should
have something that does well at this
end very
slower it's got to be the machine or
something then
because oh no it has bigger observations
is why that's fine network is slightly
different we'll get that up to a million
no problem
though oh and it's actually it's going
to be a million it's just it depends on
the configuration of a hyper param
right so let's see in the
oh that doesn't work
because yeah that doesn't work cuz we're
we don't have it yeah we just it just
truncates essentially so we're
run this already does better than before
literally it's always just hyper
prams always just hyper
prams it's like why bother manually
messing with stuff when you just Auto
solve
process and then we will see um
how this how these two
compare looks like though if we just
give this half hour or something we'll
have at least two of these Ms
done um we could
try you know what I want to do next is I
want to try to get the C side of this
working so that we have these online
so you can play uh or watch the
agents that'll be good that'll be a good
thing to do in the mean
time I mean I've got a if somebody's
going to post an iceberg
cool so if we go back to this local box
here
I have um this little piece of code
here for controlling the snake with an
MLP
I actually
have this more sophisticated Network
here
right so the question is do I just copy
paste this whole
network well I don't need this whole
network to be fair it's a little simpler
for uh for Breakout stuff so I do I just
like make the networks individually for
these it's probably the easiest
thing we'll figure out how to
reduce amount of repeated code in the
future but like this is probably pretty
easy to do so let's say that we get the
um the pong Network that we just trained
loaded into pong in C so that we can
actually have the version on the website
uh you can watch the RL AG playing the
game that' be
OBS we have OB spaces
here yeah it's just space eight and then
CER let me also get this window going
over
here this is going to be nice because
it's only going to take I don't know
what like 20 30 minutes I'm
guessing to get this network fully
andc and then that means you can run it
on the
good and then what's this multi
discreete I don't think I need this
right
eight is the input size for
now a lot of hard coding is obnoxious
but
lstm r
one
actor you just know the number of
actions here I
believe value
function
lstm return the
network
encoder oh there's no free on the lstm
there that's weird
I'm to think of it we do kind of need um
you need puffet the like puffer net. C
file to run this
[Music]
my bad I just realized that um even with
the filters on the mic carrot is just
about the most obnoxious thing I could
possibly have on
stream we'll do this
instead
oops that's a not
just it's okay
though I'm trying to think where I
should put these
files so they're usable from uh C
I guess we probably need to include um a
source or something
lstm
[Music]
manually we should probably just make
like a
discret
thing in uh
puffet why don't we do that why don't we
do that now and then we'll figure out
how to package
puffet soz that's kind of a that's kind
of a good excuse to start like a shared
utils thing
H it's funny I'm actually rethinking
this API now as well um because I know
more about C since I wrote this this is
actually kind of gross we'll leave it
for now but this is kind of
have to do
argmax discreet
what do we think the odds are that this
is correct
I probably don't even need to maintain
two separate implementations of this to
be fair I'm just going to guess that
these are probably correct for now and
uh we will clean that up
after cuz I I'm probably going to
rewrite a big chunk of this I just I
simply did not understand enough to see
when I wrote this
like it's perfectly readable but it can
be way shorter
weird yeah it's LOD it
size oh no that is
not let's just not maintain these for
now I know how we can do this easier for
now cuz that's just garbage AI code
anyways like it's probably wrong and I'm
probably going to spend a bunch of I'm
debugging it being too lazy to write it
myself don't do
oh The Struck types are going to be
different
though
well I mean
can I just like not do any of
this and just use the multi
discreete for now
object size is going to be
three one
actions like this right so soft Max
multi-
discreete multi discreete
actions it's
fine and then we actually don't need
this at all for
long just do
this stop
inin
and B
map oops
this is going to
be P weight
spin is pong
okay I need to know exactly how many
parameters this thing has don't
um
8+ 3 8+ three
okay here are weights
oops come
on me my weights
make
this okay
needs to be
free long
long we actually we don't really want
all this stuff right we kind of just
want we kind of just want this thing
this little bit of code
step
M
forward and we
[Music]
what's that what's wrong
here different
not doing any this is not doing anything
right like I can move it but it's not
doing anything on its own
because I think I just have to comment
this
there so this is now controlling it but
there is an
error because this is not the uh the
good policy that we're
expecting let's go see that build error
I'm trying to remember why this is
unsigned
let me see if there's anything else
obvious that I missed
correct I can take over the uh the game
and play it right like
it's a reu
right oh is there a decoder
wait I missed a decoder
somewhere oh wait the decoder is the
action head though isn't
it that's just the action
head so wait what do I I do I
did
encoder decoder which is
three value functions
one make
here linear reu
lstm I want to see if that's all it
is so we do
re of encode
all
right
decode
value
what you up to oh uh Hey
Spencer we have sweeps running on
breakout and
pong yeah these actually look quite good
and uh in the
meantime I have I was trying to get the
pong Network to run and
is it the correct order
actor didn't matter
function by they I mean me because it's
my
here oh wait
is it not a a
idx yeah I actually have this check
already and this is a correct
as so it says it's loaded everything
correctly
oh hold
on this could be
it do actions
pointer yeah no it has to be writing
these correctly otherwise you wouldn't
it wouldn't see anything
anything oh well I'm just dumb hold on I
loaded the wrong policy
yeah I'm super dumb hold
on yeah I'm just Giga dumb hold
on Giga Giga
oops there we
go there's our model in purec
um it's unfortunate that I didn't
realize that the C library I wrote
really needs a lot of
work but I just in the UI and like the
the way you use it really um but hey
there is a network playing pong and c
and I can actually take over for it and
I can like you know whoops I can take
over I can let it take over whenever
it's like I get the ball very close
but this thing is just categorically
better than me
so so you're kind of I'm just kind of
trolling it to be
honest if I just let it go it'll win
every Point pretty
trying to think if I want to just put
this on the web real
quick or if I want to wait until I may
as well just wait until I fix these
things properly so I don't have to do it
twice I'll commit these or I'll I'll add
I'll add these though at least
right do c
sweeps okay so here is the pong one and
here is
breakout so for pong
yeah there's really not anything that
carbs is going to do on this with the
way I have it set up so we can find
faster Solutions than this um but I'm
going to have to change the way carbs is
set up but you know regardless we're
happy with this we have pong solved for
now and then
for let's just remove this
dumb
bot why don't we just run this for like
200 mil and see what happens
likes the batch size
increment
interesting take clip
coefficient
clip for
B these are kind of crazy batch sizes
that it found
it so we go run this
for 200 mil
um triple Triad and Connect 4 we can't
really make good baselines for until we
have
um good scripted policies
that's okay we can wait on those for a
little bit see how puffer Discord is
anything
yet it's funny it's so much faster on my
uh the bigger box
meantime we're going to need to set up
the MOBA sweep for sure I want to do
that in the next hour or
so
the uh the c network stuff cuz that I'll
just do that on my own I think what I'll
do is I'm going to leave this up for now
I'm going to go make a shake I'm going
to come back I'm going to finish these
experiments I'll commit you know the
good hyper pram versions of
stuff um and then we'll try to get the
MOBA stuff maybe set up to see if that
does
anything
and yeah that'll be the main stuff here
for
stream uh yeah let me let me go get a
shake while this finishes running at
least be right back
okay our breakout model is not doing all
that well it looks like it
is it crash back down that what's going
on here it's unstable
sure every time look at
that it finds like these
wonky unstable uh results
though this doesn't match the
um this doesn't match the run from here
unless I messed up
the parameters let's kill
yeah this is correct and it's just
uh oh two update
EPO I missed that one
yeah I definitely didn't need to uh not
be manually copying
these for
for for
[Music]
I'm trying to think how we want to do
the MOBA
sweep we want to just do like an initial
an initial thing to see if it does
anything
trying to think what it is in here that
um the map
is it
stuck or is it oh it's probably doing
ELO we'll let that do what it's thing
for a
bit my breakout run oh there we
to do a sweep to fully solve
it we should be able to manage
that does anybody have a PO version that
just full solves breakout I
wonder I also don't know if our version
is easier or harder than the original
over 300 score
though
oh that's funny it actually learns to
try to like hit it to the uh to that
side
maybe so funny how it like just at the
last second
I don't think I've yeah I've never done
that well especially not on one life
holy at
that uh now it's going to be hard cuz
it's got the small
paddle how did it just
lose oh it probably just barely didn't
hit it
there so I mean that's probably
something with the environment to be
honest that looks like a good policy to
me what is wrong with this
thing this just like stuck
I don't know what this is
doing oh I think we had this problem
before yeah this does get stuck
right okay so we'll have to figure out
the Moa
M
um we got these two to mostly work
I'm trying to think what I want to do on
this
now I'm generally pretty happy with the
pong
I would have to ask Noah on the breakout
and how we uh he did some of the
stuff or actually don't I have a thing
to play it
breakout okay so here's our pong n so
right
yeah you can see right away the aspect
diens ratios are totally
Boop oh the ball does get
faster let me see so in this
one I think he just doubled
the the block
size
maybe I think he just doubled the brick
size is all he
well the the spawning of the ball is not
the
same why is pong so hard I mean why is
this so hard is the question though
something am I crazi is this paddle just
move like way too
fast yeah and then the ball speeds up
you can see
the paddle is like so I I guess it's cuz
like was the stick analog or
something the original input to
it this is like just ridiculously
hard yeah what the
[ __ ]
uh you saw that it just like went gigas
speed for some reason
yeah gigas
speed now it does reset uh the speed
when you lose a
life but that really doesn't do very
much for you
there's also this weird render thing
that happens when it like passes through
a a block or
something I think that there's like some
acceleration thing as
well trying to figure out if I can show
it
is it just miror the speed changing when
you hit
it so it does the speed changed there
but I can't tell if it changed because I
was moving the paddle
no it doesn't it changes not because you
move the paddle it changes because you
hit it four times
one
two
four and now it's fast
again and then oh the thing is it it
like it renders weird when the ball goes
through blocks that's probably just the
Atari render engine though being weird
I mean Noah said that he checked like
the original source for
this maybe he did like the arcade
cabinet version or something the
resolution is kind of interesting
yeah dude there's no way that like the
human numbers on this game are true if
this is the interface that people are
using
happening maybe if I just slow the
paddle
oh this is terrible yeah this is
terrible that's actually really funny if
you do it randomly it's very bad
weird in the actual Pawn game like these
physics are very weird
obviously like how did that just happen
right it like it can go through
diagonals like there bounce checks are
not very
oh does it not
go it just went through that block
huh
oh it actually like colors it based on
the height that's weird
Jank I see what they did with the
renderer there's no way that that didn't
hit um I want to see the the paddle
shrinking feature the
thing I have to not lose in order to see
the paddle shrinking feature but this
game is [ __ ] hard because it's so
okay it doesn't shrink to half size does
it that's like a crazy thing to shrink
to half
size let's see and then it does it does
get you your paddle size
back on your next life
fast yeah ours is actually
easier ours is easy why is ours easier
than theirs it's like the controls feel
better right is it just cuz it's
stretched that it's easier to
that yeah the physics are definitely
different
this does feel easier than the original
because the original's like [ __ ]
buggy and unfair
right yeah the aspect ratio I think is
actually hard with this one cuz like
your paddle is it's easier to control so
it feels better once you get it going
but like you can't get the ball your
paddle doesn't get to it fast
enough yeah like that I think this is
harder well you just can't control the
original
game cuz your paddle is like
moves too fast but like for an
agent that can make like these precise
Taps it's kind of weird how it just
ghost through
blocks is that intentional
Jank oh yeah and you can actually I can
tell so Noah did this right you can
actually hit the ball um after it goes
past your
paddle I think it it detects collision
with the bottom of the screen not
actually with the paddle it just checks
if your X on the paddle is in the right
spot when it hits the B botom of the
screen or
something so it looks like you can hit
it with the side of the paddle and like
you can kind of see it like going from
underneath the paddle if you look
closely
sometimes I need the exact
freaking the exact game mechanics are
very obnoxious to reproduce here
okay let's see I'm curious to see what
they say
there's
three that's
player while this can't possibly be an
expert human game player with 31 score
somebody yeah this is this is kind of a
joke from page of nature or science or
whatever by the way
I mean to be fair it's the RL
paper just that one particular
eval I don't know deep mind they're
always like these weird ways that they
claim
[ __ ] I think mostly it's like why the
aspect right ratio is so different
thing I'm somewhat more satisfied by
this now um
the paddle speed is definitely slower
though like and it's so slow that you
can't I think if you lose a life like
you have to guess which way the ball's
going to
go maybe not cuz if you're a neural net
you have perfect reaction
time but yeah like that's so fast right
by the time I react it's already too
late
I mean they said expert score was 33 at
breakout that's not
possible but I mean it does mean that
the game is as presented it's hard
yeah so that is actually on par with the
33 is but what about this
skip so somebody played this for two
hours
do I think 33 is a reasonable score to
expect with five
lives I mean I play a lot of
games I'm probably better than the
average if you just take somebody off a
street cuz I play a lot of games but I'm
not particularly good at very many of
them especially things like requiring
tight reactions like
this your reaction time is not very good
yeah
this game is Just unfair
yeah this game is Just unfair right like it just it randomly like
right like it just it randomly like
accelerates stuff it's like a quarter
eater at the arcade I guess is what this
you saw
that yeah it just freaking launches it
at
far yeah okay I believe 33 is the median
cuz the game is just [ __ ] is what it
is
it's actually surprising it's even
possible to full clear
it I guess you have to have really good
reactions not being able to hit the ball
back is sketchy though
did he copy the speed wait maybe Noah
copied the
speed but not the aspect ratio that
would make
sense you think these go at the same
rate roughly let's see
I think the one on the left is faster
isn't
it also you can go into the wall in the
original it looks like right
yeah you can go into the
wall oh but you can only go into the
wall on the right
side so
Jank I mean we don't want to
match we want to match how Jank it is
physics is so Jank on
this you can hit it like
you just have to clear a second screen
is that how it works I've never actually
gotten to the second screen but I don't
know if it's any
different huh I didn't know that this
was Zaza's game that's
cool oh this is the arcade version cool
for
so this is the aspect
ratio Noah
the only thing I think that does need to
be
fixed there's one thing with the m that
does need to be fixed so we at least
will get something out of
this but unfortunately I have to
actually clear a screen or whatever in
order to see
it if I don't do it this try I'll like
screw with the game and try to like make
it easier so I can do it but I think I
can probably do
it you actually have to be good at games
to work in RL it turns out
the ball is supposed to get
faster every before hits
it's definitely like literally too hard
to catch the initial
ball it's definitely easier though than
the original Oh and I
uh the ball the thing didn't get the
paddle didn't
instantly well actually we can fix that
very
quickly let me fix that
the initial ball should always be
slow yeah yeah yeah let's fix
that oh also
wait I might have guessed it
might have guessed how the original
works it's weird though cuz like if I
match the original I have to make it
feel
Jank okay all I have to do is hit this
four
times to
there's the fourth
hit oh yeah there goes it's faster
oh one
3 4
how the I don't understand how it's
setting the speed
okay so now we can see I got it going
very fast now it's
slow yeah it's back to slow right
for another four
hits I have to hit it four
reset
round oh so is this fixed
can you not see your paddle
withd you can't see your paddle with
okay
H I guess you see the
yeah this will be good I'll at least
I'll get this
environment oh
wait du the wrong environment
X
[Music]
Y
slowmo it's it's got the frame skip
thing on as well it's really like Ultra
hard the ball uh the breaking mechanic
is
definitely not the same as the
I want to see if this resets
correctly okay so I should it should
shrink the
paddle right
now
yep you can still play with the paddle
like this if you have perfect reflexes I
think oh no you maybe you
can't I don't know if you can actually
play with the paddle being that
small not with frame skip
on well maybe we don't need frame skip
on right
yep yeah it doesn't seem like you have
precise control enough to consistently
hit it
back maybe you're you're basically like
incrementing it
over it it's very marginal like you
might but it's very close even if you
do okay you can tell though that the
ball is the ball speed is has been
I'm not going to clear the whole thing
so I'll stop there and then uh let's fix
let's try
One okay so here
is here's our Breakout game oh yeah
that's so much smoother it's not even
close to
comparable so this is at a quarter speed
clearly yeah you have pretty darn
precise control now the thing is you
can't really choose which direction you
hit the ball with the frame skip that
high here I can actually choose
pretty much exactly what tile I'm going
to hit the ball into like maybe between
two of them but you can see how I can
actually carve this out here and keep it
from like going off at an angle it's
very hard to do uh with the frame skip
being
higher like I'll be able to recover this
nicely here
there and then the game is actually
reasonable at this speed like you can
actually play it quite
easily and even with this smaller paddle
like obviously if it were at full speed
it would
be very difficult for human
reflexes but uh you can when it's
slow and this is the max speed as well
isn't
it that the ball
goes which is I think like double the
initial speed
double I think it was it felt faster
than double
oh this is funny so it's it's a black
and white monitor with strips of
cellophane which is why it renders like
that that's funny
play oh yeah so smooth by
comparison different game completely
without the frame skip on and this
actually this one feels way better than
the original Atari to play as
well
yeah that feels way better cuz the
original game's kind of just
bullshitty you control the paddle way
too
fast I mean this is like
not easy when the uh the ball gets going
faster
here but this is at least
doable only major change is the um lack
of frame skip now it's going to be hard
with the human reflexes right your
paddle doesn't move fast enough
either H I say that but if I made it
faster I think it would be the game
would be harder
is there a second screen of bricks in
this
version I think Noah would have done
that
ever figure out y box s uh I think they
might have broken it in shipping to be
honest I've got to call them tomorrow
and be like hey this box like that you
just spent however long on it came back
you sent me two boxes back and now not
only does it crash period it's not just
crashing periodically it just doesn't
turn on
okay this feels way better it's still
very hard to clear the game
yeah this is actually kind of a good use
of time cuz I'm understanding a lot
about
like it's very funny that a lot of the
like oh you know rl's dumb it can't even
play Atari early on is like well the
Atari games are actually just stupidly
hard and like potentially not even do
when the controls are too finicky
okay let's
see so the thing that we trained with
four frame skip is perfectly happy
playing with one frame with uh no frame
skip
here it's going to vibrate a little
bit but it has absolutely no
problem doing that
actually because it probably thinks that
its actions are doing more than it does
but it's pretty
and now I'm playing the game I have
shift
like it's very easy to miss points on
the
reset for
that still substantially easier than
before without the stupid Fram skip
on probably uh for pong I wouldn't be
surprised if it's easier for the model
with frame skip but I don't know the
precise control is pretty
nice that being able to do stuff like
that yeah 14 okay cool some
substantially more
reasonable I'd say a
cool let's go back to this
box wait did this just discover anything
I'm kind of
curious I doubt that it did I bet it was
too
hard so we ran all these different
breakout runs
and the
best
score only got to like
195 too
hard for sure
and I wonder if uh if we train this
locally
wonder if this is uh going to train
perfectly with the same pams
now
oops what I mess
huh no
logs that's kind of
frequent
H hyper prams look like they've
changed which would make sense
actually frame step would change your
hyper
prams frame skip would change
looks like I got to rerun The
Sweep this doesn't work
all right that should give
us that should give us some results very
quickly this will be really good just to
have like a very fast versions of
breakout and
score we'll mess with variations of this
and such but that's pretty nice progress
on these
um I'm trying to
think probably a good
time for me to go get my exercise in and
then later in the evening I'm going to
want to fix these cap apis or this
C model library that I have figure that
out I think I should get that done
today
really this week just has to be I mean
this week it's Thursday or whatever
Friday
Thursday
Friday um yeah the next bit just has to
be lots of Dev for me to get all this
stuff done
so yeah I'm going to go do that I'm
going to I'll probably hang out in the
puffer lib voice chat for a bit uh while
I'm at the gym I'll just answer some
stuff in there if people want um and
then yeah I'll be back finishing this
later tonight make sure I didn't break
anything looks like we're good